what's up you beautiful souls welcome to
another episode of get close i'm your
co-host gio and i'm bart and today we
got another special episode because this
is q a
part two um i posted on my stories do
you guys have any questions very
embarrassingly by the way what do you
mean you were like uh so what am i
supposed to do because like i can't
check what like what what what what
the social medias okay but you're in the
social medias brother i know but i'm i
was it's
look it's just hard what are you good at
then dude literally nothing okay good
[ __ ] i can't talk anymore [ __ ] so i got
a couple of good questions and we'll get
right to it
uh fa-5 chris wants to know were you
ever insecure about geo being taller
than you
oh
for me
i was never ever insecure
were you ever insecure that i was
shorter than you what makes you never
ever insecure what
why how did that come i think if
anything i was uh
over secure
explain
so i think because
dudes are typically insecure or girls
are typically insecure
with the dude being shorter than them
i felt like because i was with you
i was like achieving the
some of unachievable
[ __ ] trophy
yeah
all right yeah was that like i was like
i tamed the lion yeah
lioness
um was i ever insecure i think in the
beginning of our relationship so you
weren't the first short guy i dated yeah
or had like a relationship with yeah so
my insecurities were
non-existent since the very beginning
right because if i wasn't a cure i would
never be in a three year plus
relationship with someone that was
shorter than me oh really maybe it was
two years maybe it was two years
uh i actually had two short boyfriends
that stereotypical thing never bothered
you like like oh like i want my guy to
like hold me like well because when i
would hear [ __ ] like that i was like
[ __ ] you're insecure
like that's why because i want him to
protect me and i'm like you think
heights gonna protect you height's not
gonna do [ __ ] for you if this full can't
run fast if he's not athletic if he's
not like
lifting if he's not like a guy you know
what i mean like if he doesn't have like
some sort of testosterone in his body
yeah
like height ain't gonna mean [ __ ] so i
wanted someone that was capable instead
of someone that's just tall but like is
[ __ ] scrawny like i want to feel
little i'm like
okay
but like can he really protect you yeah
yeah who knows
um my boyfriends that were shorter could
i felt like they could protect me you
know
um
so
i didn't care about the height if they
weren't
if they were capable i see so capability
was more important than the height 100
and um confidence if they felt insecure
about being with me then i'm like
oh my god that this thing just height is
gonna make you
feel bad about yourself you're on weak
foundation like
we're not even on the same plane yeah i
remember you saying that like uh tim
although he's like five three but he
feels like someone that's six feet tall
yeah that's very attractive that's way
more important than somebody that is
actually six feet but feels yeah i've
met so many tall guys that are like oh i
just wish i was i'm not even at all i
wish i was like a little bit taller and
i'm like
you are too weak for me dude
um so because of that it never made me
feel insecure
um i just always wanted to make sure
that my partners felt good so like when
i was with you and we were first
together in the first i love wearing
high heels and i love dressing up and
[ __ ] like that uh even though i don't
look like it right now because bart has
the [ __ ] ac at literally like 61 and
i'm freezing my nose literally i think
73. well i think this [ __ ] is broken
okay because our 73 in our other [ __ ]
room is different than this one this one
that feels like it's 63.
um
yes i just wanted to make sure you felt
comfortable so when the first time i
would wear like high heels and stuff and
there is like the four inches of
difference
i was just like are you gonna be okay so
i think i felt insecure for you no i
wasn't until you were like i was like i
don't give a [ __ ] yeah my [ __ ] hot
[ __ ] my elephant is bigger than you
thought
can i be a giraffe my giraffe is taller
than you thought yeah yeah so i never
yeah i never felt
insecure about that
will you ever um
asks will you ever franchise bb
and what will it take to franchise it
[Music]
that was a funny reaction
oh man so this has been our first brick
and mortar
business mine
uh first real alone business
um because when i i learned a lot of
business doing you know working
for
or with jk
that i was able to bring a lot of it
with me and i built a lot of confidence
in me and like i'm like wow i'm really
capable of a lot of [ __ ]
and um
so but it was an online business
there's no there's no real overhead
there's no brick and mortar type [ __ ]
right
and then starting a gym
and then all these other
things
for the gym right so there's a gym the
supplement arm there's a
there's the apparel there's a
productions there's like a lot of other
businesses that
attached to it
that like
we've just been i've just been going
through a lot of trial and error with
every single one because every single
business model has to run differently
yes the operation part of it are all
very similar that's why you can see a
lot of these ceos going from industry to
industry because operation wise
um
uh or just like ceo and
it's very similar it doesn't matter what
industry you're in
um
but they all function so differently
that i
i'm like
i just want to really refine things and
bring them up to a level that i'm super
proud of before i can start expanding
anything
yeah that's where i'm at too i'm not
against the idea i just think everything
is about timing and the right place yeah
because if you scale something that has
problems the problems scaled as well as
the good stuff
so i'm not open i'm not uh against it
i'm definitely down to franchise it but
it would have to be like at a point
where i feel like it is [ __ ] and span
yeah everything is like really
at least above 95 of what i think it can
be yeah then we will scale it and then
that way as we're scaling um
the the problems are like
manageable yeah and also um
you know we have to remember that like
we invested 10 years of our life
you know with jk
and within those 10 years i want to say
the last like eight obviously because
we've been in it for eight years um you
know we
not even ate six years we were hitting
it hard at both we were building barbell
and we were building jk we were building
our own personal stuff and there was
like a lot of building and stacking of
you know chips and and assets and stuff
um that once we knew we were going to
have taiko we
we we said we're in a very stable place
right now
um that we can back off of the hustle
and now put that hustle mindset into our
family so things naturally have to slow
down so because we're in that phase
right now where we're building and
stacking these ships with our family we
you know within the internal love and
and setting good morals and foundation
for our son and our
our own relationship and our own like
little family dynamic here that um all
the other stuff because it's stable and
it's doing well um we can back off on it
but once we see that taika is a little
bit more independent and needs us less
which is it feels like it's right around
the corner it really feels like it's
right around the [ __ ] corner really
every month i swear taika is such an
independent person like the taika he was
in jiu jitsu last year versus this year
yeah yeah holy crap it's such a
different case how old does he have to
be before he let him walk to school by
himself let's say let's say we live the
block away man i grew up in the [ __ ]
hood so i don't know if i'll ever feel
comfortable
because i just know how easy things
happen
you know i know how bad people work
i don't know i've seen too many things
we live in a really good neighborhood i
know but i've seen too many things and
if it's not necessary then it's not
necessary
um
but yes once we see that taika has more
independence we have no other choice to
[ __ ] go at it again because that's
just what we know how to do we only
we're builders you know and we like
building and we love working and we like
uh building things that are very uh fun
and and um
um we really enjoy so
i i don't see why we wouldn't go in that
route in anything that we do but right
now it seems like things are slowing
down possibly i don't know if you guys
see it on the outside but like we're so
focused on family right now that like
all the other things are just kind of
like cool
i didn't even let you answer no i did i
did answer oh okay cool
um okay this one i think is more for me
moises rodriguez thirteen asks why do
you kill me
moses why do you keep gaining weight and
losing weight yeah but why i swear
together you've cut six times in these
last two years no i have not cut six
times in the last few years but i do
gain weight and lose weight so
um for me i think it's a personal
journey and personal endeavor
where um
i'm trying to conquer not really my
physical because i've done it before but
or like my physical realm okay i think
i've conquered my physical realm i'm
more trying to conquer my momental realm
and spiritual realm
so like um growing up i've always been
the tiny kid right like i'd even break a
hundred pounds until i was 15 years old
so i was skinny scrawny
and uh from high school from freshman
year till senior year
i was like man i got to put on some
weight um i want to be strong i won't
have muscle so i lifted my ass off and
by the time i graduated high school i
think i was about
165. i was very proud of it i was like
and i benched like 265 and i was like i
felt really like really proud of what i
put put on
damn 265 165
yeah
i uh went to boot camp
come back out 1 30.
so i'm super small small again
because you're really malnourished there
you know and it's just non-stop cardio
so i started pounding the weights again
pounding food i got myself up to about
like i think like 210 maybe 215
and i was kind of big i was just doing
like the dirty bulking bodybuilder
lifestyle and then when it came time to
getting promoted in the marine corps you
have to do well on your pft and you have
to like have regs like regular pft
physical fitness test oh fitness disc so
oh [ __ ] i haven't been running
so i need to run and also my
i'm kind of big in the midsection now so
i'm going to get down because like you
know like in the marine corps leaders
lead from the front
so you got to be able to run with your
troops you got to be ahead you know like
you got to be just as capable anyone
else and
you'll notice like what's interesting is
as you go up in rank the busier you are
right you have more like responsibility
but those guys actually trained the
hardest too
like the higher ranking guys they
trained really hard
so i was like okay i gotta get myself in
shape started running a lot more and
that's when i kind of went back down to
like about like 180 mid 180ish and
that's what i held on to for a very long
time like i felt like that was pretty
comfortable i was strong and athletic
and then i uh
uh that's when i was like doing most of
my jk at around 180 190. i did my first
powerlifting me oh and then i got really
into crossfit because then that's when
like functional fitness
uh came in it was like a really big deal
so i really got into that and i got down
oh it's cool yeah i got down to like 175
and we're playing basketball all the
time so running to the park running to
the park doing crossfit there running
back playing basketball
um and that was probably the latest i
got for a while i was like 175 and then
so when i did my first powerlifting meet
i saw some state records that i thought
i could break so i dropped down to
165 to compete i didn't break them but i
did hit some pretty cool prs i
deadlifted 500 or 501 at 165 at that
time i was a top 50 deadlifter in the
nation which is really really cool
across federations
and then i got really into powerlifting
and into powerlifting i started you know
having like my own new idols and what i
looked up to and so i really want to
just put on sizes and powerlifting
really benefits you when you're a big
square
so i started getting heavier heavier
heavy heavier got from 165 back up to my
normal weight 180 190. you saw me
compete there a couple times and then i
was like you know what i'm gonna just
bulk and see if i can hit some of these
lifetime numbers that i wanted which is
bench 400 deadlift six squat five got
all the way up to 230
and uh when i got up to 230
um i came really close to benching 400
bench 391 wow competition plates i
benched oh i deadlifted six but my squat
was 475. i think squad was like had a
confidence issue skill issue all that
that form was pretty wet yeah my form
skill issue
and then i was like i just wanted to
talk [ __ ] fine thank you and i felt
really like nasty like i was just out of
breath all the time and then so i
started cutting back down
and you were so close and now i'm so
close i probably should have just bought
kept lucky for another three months i
would hit 405 for sure started cutting
back down and then i was hovering around
like a 180 190 uh for a while
and for some reason uh when we're about
to have taika
i figured i was just gonna get lean i
don't know why because you're an [ __ ]
probably and i don't know why i'm like
this is the [ __ ]
craziest i'm ever gonna look heaviest
i'm ever gonna be and you're like
i'm gonna be like my peak god physique
and i'm like
i think maybe i don't know maybe i'll
just so sick of being fat so i started
you know scaling back down so right
around when we had taika i was lean
again that's what i was like look good
in all the photos like the cover of uh
get lean photos probably when taika was
like like one or two maybe around there
or like maybe even before he was one and
then i trained for a marathon um didn't
really care about how it looked i really
just wanted to make sure i was able to
run the whole time
and then pandemic happened
pandemic happened i was actually pretty
lean throughout the pandemic too until
we moved and then like we got all this
pandemic food so we're like we don't
want to go to waste so i started eating
the frozen pizzas or whatever but i was
still leaning out and you didn't give a
[ __ ] oh well cause i'm like i'm gonna if
we're gonna get rid of this food i might
as well do a good job so if there's two
pizzas i'll eat two pizzas at a time so
i started eating all that food started
gaining the weight and then you know i
just caught the yummy food bug again so
i just started going
yeah for two years you were just like
going ahead and going ham and then not
even knowing how much i weighed
in my mind i kept thinking i was 190.
and then i forgot what it was but for a
shoot
um i think it was with silent mic or
something but for a shoot i was at the
the
gym scale at barbell
i stood on it and it said 224 with my
clothes on i'm like 224
what the
it's all okay this is unacceptable
and uh i'm like
i do want to chase you feel bad for me
were you like god damn it poor geo no
because every year i check in with you
because i know attraction's a huge thing
so every year i go hey does this turn
you off is this turning off and you
always say no i'm like no i don't care
i'm like cool so i always check in with
you because i want to make sure i'm
attract you're attracted to me too
and then uh i end up hitting my
500 squat i got 5 15. really happy about
that because usually when my weight
comes down that's the first thing that
goes
got that and then so now i'm coming back
down and uh the goal right now is to be
the leanest i've ever been
while being strong and then i'm just
going to keep that and i think that's
going to be my best overall like dad
physique uh best physique to go into jiu
jitsu with to do all the other endeavors
i want to do in life and also still look
good for photo shoots and all that yeah
yeah that's my journey thank goodness
i feel like you've done it fat skinny
fats getting way more than that but
those are the big ones i mean it feels
like i might have done a few little mini
cuts mini bulks here and there but
that's generally like my
whole trajectory it just feels like like
a lot but after this
i'm just gonna maintain and just keep it
there cool yeah
next one uh
speaking of being fat benji thongzi's
ass are you guys making a video series
for the get lean challenge
well we actually are
yeah we are so uh we
have um 12 episodes planned out for the
12 weeks of the get lean programs if you
get the get lean program
um it is 12 weeks long
and uh
we have two episodes uploaded to the
barber brigade channel already so make
sure you go check that out the first one
is just our waze or dexa scan we want to
get baseline numbers as accurate as
possible our second video is our most
intense workout from wave one because
there's three waves three main four main
waves in there
and uh we're going to be documenting
this this whole series so i think this
is cool because uh well and you're
missing the biggest piece here
you and i are doing it together and
we're competing against each other yeah
so there's a couple pieces
the other thing that i was going to say
that's a big piece is i think for a lot
of people because their weight loss
journey is by themselves
um it's difficult you know it's easier
when you do things in a group yeah which
is why we want to make it a competition
or it's a community-based theme so it
doesn't matter if you're in australia or
singapore we can do this together with
the series so you feel like we're all
doing it together and
uh i think in july or august we're gonna
hold the get lean event at the gym so
everyone that's running it let's all go
and just lift together have a really
good time so we're trying to have that
thing which is the community
international community doing it
together and then to make it competitive
you and i are competing with each other
yeah
um
oh lots of getting questions okay cool
cool
georgie dominguez asks do you think
there will be a time that you will no
longer be influencers aka retired
um
well
i don't think either one of us ever set
out to be an influencer
um we're literally just living our life
and like um
we're just doing the [ __ ] that we find
fun so you don't
uh
categorize yourself as an influencer no
what's the definition of an influencer
and what's the definition of what you're
doing i don't know i feel like an
influencer is someone that wants to
um
put all of their [ __ ] out there right
this is not what we do i know right as
soon as i said that i was like
okay so i think so okay the reason why i
said it like that was um i personally
never wanted to be on camera right but
it was because of the work that i was in
with you guys that we just needed it to
be that way so then it kind of just
organically happened that way
so
um
if i were to fade away in the blackness
i'm totally cool
and it's not something that i'm aspiring
to
like keep and maintain like i'm not i'm
not someone i don't want to
um continue to be
like in the in like in the camera so
eventually i would want to like just
be gone
that that would be like an ultimate goal
of mine is to um and i don't know how
realistic that is right because
technology is is changing so much and
the landscape is changing so much like
even our our business meetings now that
used to be held in person are now online
so um
like grocery shopping i do that online
like everything is happening online that
i don't know how feasible or how
realistic this goal of this eventual
goal of mine is to just be completely
off the grid yeah
um in terms of like social media and
stuff
um but if i am on it it'll just be
because
i'm just trying to uh create some
memories
so that's what i mean like i don't i'm
not aspiring to stay on it like i'm not
like going please let me be here ah you
know
yeah i think um
i think
the term influencer has changed over the
years yeah it used to be really bad
because for for me i think
i wanted to do comedy
the social media aspect
was just a way for that to happen and to
get the content out
and also even with fitness i just want
to be in fitness yeah and i think the
social media con uh concept is just to
help get that out yeah it's like an
amplifier that's what it was yeah yeah
and um
and i think uh with the vlog stuff where
we show our families i think that's a
little bit more towards the influencer
side of things um but i would say it
evolved there because uh i think the
term influencer now it's people
that want to be on social media yeah
right so yeah so the social media is the
thing rather than the amplifier which is
why you'll sometimes see a fitness
person doing a dance
it's because they're just doing whatever
they can to maximize the social media
aspect of it not so much the fitness
aspect of it and i think for for me
um
i wanted to maximize comedy so even so
if the skit was the funniest i'll put
that out there i don't write the skits
to get the most views i sprite the skits
to get to be the funniest you know so in
that regard i'm not the best influencer
because i'm not working the algorithm or
whatever i'm trying to more focus on the
art same thing with like our our fitness
brand bar brigade and stuff like that um
so for me
because of that if i end up uh running
out of the thing that i want to do i
could totally see myself not being a
influencer yeah but like if i found
myself like let's say
uh writing or directing and i had such a
big avenue there that i didn't need
social media to amplify i probably
wouldn't use it yeah 100 because i see
it as a tool rather than the theme yeah
yeah but nothing against people that use
it as the theme no the people that are
using it as a thing um are [ __ ]
smashing and you can tell because they
have like top-notch quality they know
hooks yeah yeah they know the algorithm
they know all everyone in their their
immediate
circle their competitors like they're on
it yeah and that's why like like you i
don't consider myself an influencer
either yeah
this episode of get close is brought to
you by ziprecruiter i'm super excited to
travel this summer because one of my
favorite things about traveling
is experiences right and have you
noticed that the most impactful
experiences from vacations or
restaurants or the places that you go is
generally from outstanding staff whether
it's the hotel concierge that makes you
feel extremely warm and welcome into
their family
or it's the tour guide who knows how to
tie in the physical places with personal
stories
or
the waiter or server who knows how to go
above and beyond what's just listed on
the menu the way they describe the food
or they find out what your interest is
they can
purposefully
and very
well pair what you're looking for with
like another drink
and all of these people are outstanding
talent and that is crucial for
successful business and if you're hiring
you can find talent for roles like these
and more as a recruiter when you try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com
get close us
at barber brigade we have personally
used it before and it is freaking
awesome because they have a powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates with your job and you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply so you can even look for people
that haven't applied specifically for
your position but you're looking for
those positions and you can find the
people that have already submitted so on
the other side if you're applying and
you're well qualified candidate
people are scouting all the time so
remember
when you want to upgrade your business
this summer make sure to find the top
talent at ziprecruiter.com
get close that's where you can try it
for free that's ziprecruiter.com
get close
um
hln 712 asks what's the best advice for
an interracial couple
what's the best advice for an
interracial couple
um
there needs to be a lot of understanding
i don't know what races we're talking
about right like if we're if it's
mexican to chinese there's a lot of
similarities and there's like a lot of
crossover um so
it's not very difficult
to understand where you're coming from
with certain things and vice versa
but if it's something that's super
extreme like
i don't know i can't think of any right
do you think there's an obstacle there
though like because we're both american
right but do you think there's still a
gap between mexican american and chinese
i think there would be uh for sure
really would be
um
but i think what helped us and this is
the piece of advice that i would want to
give is that i actually
hung out with a lot of asian people i i
not that i went out of my way to study
it right but to a certain extent i am
studying the culture i am studying the
interactions i am listening to how they
say things like i'm i'm definitely
trying to be respectful of the culture
and trying to um
um
like
still have that in our relate like in
our friendship even yeah um so like uh
i i really do try to understand where it
comes from and i'm really trying to take
their culture and just be like oh okay
let me be respectful about this like
these are your customs cool i understand
it like anything that i can take from
the culture so that i can understand it
so that i can
treat them with respect and honor that
then
then i think that's really helpful
is there a um
would you say there's a difference
between interracial friendships and
interracial couples
yes
there is yes
i think there's more leeway with the
friendship okay right like if you um
fumble on certain customs or whatever or
if you say
um things that are like a little bit out
of line i think there's more leeway
right because it's like well you didn't
know but when it comes to a
actual relationship now you're dealing
with your significant other but you're
also dealing with their family and like
there's just so many more elements to it
and you guys are together every single
day so for yours it's more about um
making sure there's the correct
communication and understanding yeah
because when you come from different so
already you're coming from different
families right those are already
different sets of values
um upbringing all that stuff right
family dynamic how they talk to each
other all that and then you add another
layer which is a cultural difference
that's that's really stressful if you
are not respectful to that even being a
thing
[Music]
yeah
would you say that
um
is it easier than to be same race
couples
for certain things it would be easier
yeah because then you guys are already
on the same page yeah right like let's
say let's say you you grew up buddhist
right and this is more of a religious
thing but it tends to work out this way
also with cultures but you're buddhist
i'm catholic i want to put taika now to
start doing his like first communion for
example and you're going to be like well
why
you know i'm booted like my family and
all that we didn't have to do any of
that stuff but if we were both catholic
and we grew up because catholicism is
really
big in in mexicans um or mexican culture
then it's it's a it's already a given
it's like as soon as he became this age
it's like oh hey we should already start
picking his nino and nina's you know
like it's already uh we're speaking the
same language already
i see yeah yeah i think um
for me i never saw
interracial couples as a hurdle
ever since i was a kid because i've been
having uh interracial friends and so
i've always been already trying to like
seek understanding on both ways you know
like
and i think maybe that helped out with
me just being open-minded as a kid
because i remember going to my best
friend uh
he was filipino his house
and there was like four grandmas that
lived there and i was like oh [ __ ]
that's cool
and then we were like walking around the
house and their master bedroom
isn't where the parents live
isn't that crazy their master bedroom
is like six twin size beds
so they have a kid's room
isn't that cool
so the the parents they didn't see it as
like this is the grown-up one they just
thought this has the most space we need
to put let's put all the kids in here
and i'm like how fun it's literally a
slumber party so there's uh there's like
six beds in there so there was i think
two or three families that lived it was
a big house but it was like two or three
families that lived there so the cousins
slept with each other they all lived
there then uh one
uh set of parents lived in one room that
was not the master another set of
parents lived in another
room that was not the master
and there was the random like uh
unmarried older uncle that lived in the
attic with all the pornos that we would
always sneak up to go check out yeah and
i just thought wow this is so cool
because like yours you always think
things are set a certain way you know
master bedroom parents go in there yeah
and when i went there i was like oh
that's so cool
and um
then i would go to like my friends my
other friend's house who was interracial
like his parents was a half white half
chinese and i would just hear his
parents like have a conversation with
them and i'm like wow that's so cooner
even have a conversation with my parents
it's a one-way street you know yeah and
uh so just like seeing how things could
be picking and choose what i liked i
always just knew that like uh
you always have to
seek understanding regardless if you're
the same race or not yeah and maybe
because i was blessed with that where i
was the minority like i think we were
the only chinese family on the block i
always felt like
getting that rapport you have to
establish yeah versus i think it might
be different where like let's say
all your friends are asian and all of a
sudden you're dating someone white
then it's like uh and if you go to their
family's house and they're all white too
then it might be a huge culture shock
because you never had to establish
rapport before the whole community was
already on shorthand yeah you know uh
but i think for me every relationship i
ever had was already i had to establish
reports so it became like just second
nature ah i see
yeah no i didn't have that i think just
growing up um i was always just so
different and so fascinated
by
different cultures the only one i had
the most access to were like japanese
and chinese people so because of that i
was so intrigued and like
um just so curious as to like
like how they live so differently than
me and the people i grew up around
because all mexican people that i was
around did the same [ __ ] the same way we
did so it was just normal but it wasn't
until i started having friends that
weren't mexican that i go to their house
and i'm like oh [ __ ] you guys use food
scissors what the [ __ ] are these food
scissors and they just look like regular
scissors but you just use it on food and
[ __ ] like that would blow my mind yeah
you know like wait you take your shoes
off because it's dirty yeah that makes
sense
oh [ __ ] so your grandma okay so wait you
have to live here and then your grandma
has this say and then oh we don't eat
until this person oh you're not supposed
to shake their hand oh it's a bowing oh
[ __ ] that's so interesting how cool
you know um another thing i would say is
is
don't take everything personally when
they don't understand your background
because right now
um or at least when i was growing up
it just felt like uh when i was
introducing
my family members that are of older
generations they would ask questions
that seem so [ __ ] ignorant and so
um
you know out of touch if you will
that like i i would get so defensive
because i was used to just being like
what the [ __ ]
like erase color lines and don't be a
racist and this stuff right that i would
just like like what the [ __ ] like are
they trying to be racist but it wasn't
until i was able to put that aside where
i'm like oh [ __ ] they're genuinely
curious
right so i can either attack that and be
[ __ ] condescending and like try to
set them straight or i could just be
like oh [ __ ] wait i think that's my own
insecurity and my own ego let's put that
aside and let's really hear what they're
asking oh [ __ ] they really want to get
to know them and they really don't know
yeah like they really do not know like
one of the questions i got asked once
was like um and this was by one of my
elderly family members
years ago and they were like wait so
what did they eat all day just like egg
rolls and stuff because
for us the mexican food we had i mean
the chinese food we had in the [ __ ]
hood were like those fast like china
express yeah those take out places those
takeout places right um and it didn't
have very much very variation other than
like those few things that we would see
because we loved eating chinese food but
like now that i know better i'm like
that's actually like not that good yeah
um and i remember going like what the
[ __ ] and then going wait but
you've never interacted with
any asian people they really only stayed
in your bubble yeah and i remember
having that thought in my head where i'm
about to like [ __ ] attack and then i
went oh [ __ ] wait this is what your
background is oh wait wait okay and i
calmed down and then i was able to
explain and
she was just so fascinated and was like
oh [ __ ] do you think you could take me
out and try it i've never even heard of
these things and it sounds cool and i'm
like oh look at me and i was about to
bash you you know so having that
patience and not taking things
personally and just being there um to
help educate especially when you meet
the family members because some of them
are even less exposed than you are yeah
yeah yeah that's what i mean
yeah um because that was something i
learned where i was like about to start
defending you know i'm gonna defend it
at all costs and then i'm like wait why
do i need to defend if there's nothing
to really defend yeah so that was
another another thing i had to yeah one
thing with the whole like shoes taking
off thing
um we all knew on our street
like whose house you have to take shoes
off of and who
doesn't so when we picked tat when we
played tag we even knew whose house to
play at but oh let's play like mark's
house you have to take your shoes off so
you can run in and out and in and out of
the house if we go to the asian people's
houses like my house or the korean guy's
house or whatever then
it's gonna be a nuisance because as soon
as you get through the front door you
have to take your shoes off carry it
walk to the backyard put it back on and
when you're trying to play tag you're
trying to be as fast as you can yeah
even sometimes how fun you guys would
play tag within houses yeah like in and
out of the house like we just knew okay
if we want this we go like
our four best friends
all lived in that same uh street how
cool so when we wanted to play like we
just knew okay we're gonna play like
over here like we can i can go to my
front lawn and see if my other friends
are like playing in the front yard or
not how cool
it's cool huh that's super cool
um
cool cody ng96 asks how did you both
work through conflicts and fights early
in your relationship
early in the relationship you're so
stupid
you always think you're right you're
stupid in the relationship and also
early in life too yeah
yeah there's double stupidity super
stupidity and we were together in our
mid-20s
so like we would get into fights and it
was literally like one of us going
after a while mainly probably bart
i probably knew i was wrong and didn't
even realize that i knew that i was
wrong and then go on like why would he
make me feel like this and blah and i
would just not resolve it like i just
was like i'm not going to resolve it
today i don't want to deal with it today
and it was probably bart coming in and
going can we talk about it and then go
ah and then like me getting angry again
and then you getting angry again and
then we're both [ __ ] angry and
nothing really gets resolved
and it wasn't until like we really
started
at least for myself it wasn't until i
really started looking at myself and
like these aspects of like areas that i
didn't like in terms of like how i would
solve problems or when i was feeling sad
how i would react because i didn't react
with sadness and i didn't tell you that
i was sad i would just react with anger
and it was more more with [ __ ]
okay fine um would you still stem from
anger dude yeah um but [ __ ] is better
fine it's funny it's better no it's a
better word because it's more
encompassing fine [ __ ] you
so like i started recognizing my own
patterns of like [ __ ] when x happens y
reaction comes out and then i was like
wait but that's not how he meant it or
that's not how the situation went down
why am i taking things so personally or
like why did i react this way if i'm sad
why am i getting angry if i'm sad i
should say hey you know what that thing
that you did made me really sad
so it was like me taking a step back and
recognizing
what i was feeling during these like
intense moments
um and then being able to
to really see past the emotion and be
like oh [ __ ] you know what i think is
really happening i think one of us is
sad
i think the other one like made the
other person really upset or
disappointed and it wasn't always just
about an anger
um
uh
an angering situation it was like oh
damn
i think i really disrespected him
or like oh [ __ ] this is a sensitive
subject instead of me just already
getting defensive and going well what
the [ __ ] why do you have to talk like
that you know and it doesn't
ever help anything
yeah but it was just really it was it
was just really looking at myself first
and fixing my own [ __ ] before i can like
put it on you
yeah one thing i think i realized uh
later on
because you have to go through a lot of
fights and then a lot of self-reflection
to figure out
what is really causing a lot of it
and it was me realizing that people
don't really get upset
or when someone's upset
it's not really them talking it's their
traumas talking yeah you know like when
someone gets a get gets upset about
something because something's not going
their way right now
it could be when they were a kid nothing
went their way so now this is their time
to control but they're not even aware or
a conscious of that it's their trauma
talking
so knowing that um me kind of giving
things a little bit more leniency as i'm
talking and hearing things help ease my
mind and not be so
um
like rebuttaly yeah you know because
it's like it's easy to get defensive and
go like why are they taking it that way
what the [ __ ] i'd say like this
but then that's also meaning you're
having uh your head up your own ass
and you're speaking from your own trauma
because you don't want to be wronged you
know so you've been wrong so many times
that you're like i finally fixed it and
i know how to word things now how come
i'm still wronging this person or how
can i probably see it that way so it's
just two people having a fight out of
their own personal traumas versus if
both people are actually level-headed
and they're aware of their traumas and
they are they're aware of how they need
to speak to each other to solve things
their word word choice tone choice is
way different well i think something
that helped disarm that for me
was really really trusting you
right and like of course i trust you
and when i'm saying this trust i'm not
talking about like oh you're going to
cheat on me or oh you're going to steal
from me or you're living a double life
like that's not the type of trust i'm
talking about the type of trust that i'm
talking about is that i can
say something that i feel
um
very vulnerable sharing or that i feel
is going to be stupid or childish and i
trust that when i put it on the table
for you to see this thing or whatever my
insecurity is
i trust that you're not going to laugh
at it and you're going to take it as
serious as i am
and that's the first step that really
helped me um in opening up a lot more i
felt that that like we had created or we
had finally created a space where
we could really say anything and the
other person wasn't gonna take it
personally so i can tell you hey you
know what your [ __ ] breath smells
every [ __ ] morning and it pisses me
off and i'm sorry that it pisses me off
but i [ __ ] hate it and instead of you
being like well what the [ __ ] you also
have bad breath in the morning why the
[ __ ] is it on me why don't you check
instead of you doing that it was more
like
oh [ __ ] okay so why do you think it why
do you think it offends you so much
i'm like [ __ ] you know what i don't know
so instead of you like taking it
personally and as a personal attack it
was more so like okay this is jio's
issue that she's working on
how can i help guide her
in like seeing this issue out
and then if it hurts you at the end of
it then you'd be like hey so really my
breath smells and that like like do you
did you want me to change that and but
after i've resolved whatever i needed to
resolve i'm going like oh no actually
it's not even about you and most of the
time if it's it's probably like 90 of
the time our problems weren't even about
the other person yeah it really wasn't
about the other person it was really
about ourselves and our trauma and like
the unhealed [ __ ] child and [ __ ] that
was like like holding on to this one
situation and like making a big [ __ ]
catastrophic problem out of it
um and overreacting out of it and it was
both of us just like
[ __ ] two little kids just having
tantrums with each other yeah one
sentence that i read that i was like wow
that's pretty deep and it takes a lot
but once you understand and if you can
apply it
then um
a lot more conflicts would be smooth
sailing and it's by mark ronson
uh the author of the settle art of not
giving a [ __ ] and he says
is it is that what it's called a subtle
art i'm not giving a [ __ ] is that what
it is oh okay wait i was confusing two
books and i was like wait did you just
confuse two titles my bad and then he
says um
you can't help what you feel
but you can control how you react to
those feelings yeah and i'm like wow
that blew my mind because i think most
people forget
that there's actually a gap
right most people go here's my senses
whether it's my feelings my eyes my ears
whatever here's my senses i feel
and then boom there's my action but
actually it's i feel
how do i process those feelings
and then
my reaction and i think the more and
more you're aware and the people that
are very aware of that gap and have full
control of the gap hard that gap is uh
what is like the key to having
successful or unsuccessful relationship
you know someone could say something
that's insulting
and then they say it and if you're man
[ __ ] you back or you
why wait why did that insult like you
feel obviously you can't help what you
feel right you're just you're feeling
man i felt like [ __ ] wait why did why
did that
rub me that wrong way
and then you can process and think and
go okay how do i how do i respond to my
own emotions because your brain and your
heart are two different organs we
operate as if it's like one but it's two
right so okay let's use the brain now
why does my heart feel this way and then
respond back and that has helped so much
too yeah versus like if you just say
something and i just get pissed and i
just retaliate and then it ends up going
nowhere yeah and also in an argument um
we aren't really listening to understand
you know like if you really just try to
understand the person
again by not taking things personally
then you can you can have that
separation of the brain and the heart um
and have that time that little buffer
section where you're like oh [ __ ] okay
this is what they're really trying to
communicate um what was the question how
did we get over it um yeah how do we how
do we deal with like early uh
fights and conflicts in the relationship
how did we deal with it like [ __ ]
savages we didn't deal with him we were
fighting all the goddamn time we were
fighting literally every day
um it was horrible we were animals yeah
all right next one
joseph hohn wants to ask
what foods are you craving right
all of them dude all of them someone
could tell you like if someone go
right whatever you see right now
like that i had right in front of me
what is it uh pizza straight from italy
like a big [ __ ] extra-large pizza
juicy and then i want some pistachio
gelato oh yes
i'm like on a gold man just give me
pasta while you're at it give me some
french [ __ ] baguettes and some
croissants yeah warm out of the oven
when you bite it's like
yes you want some quality [ __ ] you know
what i want
mcdonald's gross
i just want like a
large coke
some fries
some burger with sodium and it just gets
me bloated no what else do i want
i want some udon like some high quality
ass udon i could probably eat that now
but
too many carbs in that [ __ ]
um oh god donuts give me some krispy
kremes donuts what kind of cheese what
kind of cheese we talk about any drippy
cheese like any like pizza any like
cheese nacho i want some carne asada
[ __ ]
what did i say like that carne asada
[ __ ] nachos from king taco oh you
know what's been popping up on my feet
too
tacos are bomb
let me get some of that a [ __ ] root
beer float what else do i want to eat
right now you know what's crazy
cheesecake some strawberry [ __ ]
cheesecake what do you think about it 12
weeks isn't a long time it's not it's
like three months right but then you go
and i've been eating all this [ __ ] for
half years [ __ ] complaining for two
years right i've been eating for two
years
and it's like oh i can't handle it
without for three weeks and i'm like why
is my urge is so crazy
i see taika because he's eating anything
he wants he's loving it is he eating
eminent like this peanut butter i mean
those peanut m ms
peanut butter i just want some peanut
butter i know
what else what else do i want
damn i've been like going in you don't
want anything
mainly mcdonald's and what would you
order from mcdonald's oh like a double
quarter pounder with cheese and uh
with mac sauce and then fish fillet and
then a six-piece chicken nugget
and um mcflurry and then large coke with
extra ice i actually did you see the new
big mac like meal or something i could
actually eat that by myself so there's
like a new like two for one like big mac
meal there's two big macs it's two big
disgusting two big disgusting two big
macs plus 20 chicken nuggets what and
two drinks
i could eat the whole wonder [ __ ]
everyone's obese right now
i think it's made for two but i can eat
all by myself yeah how many people are
really gonna [ __ ] share that
that's horrible dude all that food is so
[ __ ] bad
what once once a month maybe
you know right after this i'm a dmr
coach i'm like when's our uh
no god damn it you
just [ __ ] put your head down and do
the [ __ ] work don't already start
[ __ ] dangling a carrot pretend
check it out this is what you gotta do
pretend a carrot is never gonna be
dangled just [ __ ] pretend it's gonna
be 12 weeks of horse so when it does
surprise you when he's like hey refeed
you're gonna be like yes
[Laughter]
you're the worst i [ __ ] love food i
don't even know i do know because you're
[ __ ] always trying to cheat hey so
there's like these crab legs
i wasn't cheating on the crab legs i
didn't cheat at all yeah
that whole meal was all [ __ ] in oil
dude nope nope but it was we no
what
no
[ __ ] cheat it was
not it was shrimp crap yeah
what kind of shrimp
they probably sauteed it in butter
and that's why it tasted so bomb
what shrimp by itself is driest and
guess what they took it out of the
butter
so they sauteed in the butter and they
took it out of the butter okay i didn't
drink the sauce
you ate the shrimp that's doused in it
dude yeah they doused and i un-doused it
how i didn't see you dip it in no water
i went like this
anyway and then there's a shrimp
cocktail you're the worst nah i love
food you spent 200 for some [ __ ] ass
meal that still made your ass fat
no i gotta lean from that one
i'm fine
you're gonna lose this competition no no
no no no all right
uh this is probably our last question
by mahir 98
how to combat work fatigue
especially
from a work from home setting
oh
this is actually uh
one of the reasons why i think
oh i don't think work from home is
actually a good thing it's not a good
thing i think it takes i don't think
it's good at all but a lot of lazy
people are like
finally dreams come true and i'm like
y'all don't even know and the reason why
they don't know i actually think
it takes a highly disciplined person
to have a tub of ice cream in front of
you and not eat it
right so when you work from home all
your comforts are there your bed your
whatever everything is there right
you're even in jamas if you wanted to
and um
now you have to
yeah you have to
always constantly resist whereas when
you're in a workplace
it's
very clear-cut you know all those
comforts aren't there
and because everyone's peers there's a
duty to like uphold the standard so
everyone you're just operating on a
different wavelength
and that wavelength helps power you
through a lot of stuff versus having all
these constant like temptations
that
coupled with
um
your work is at home now
i don't like that feeling so when we
were first building our companies we
couldn't afford anything so obviously
our office was also our house
and it doesn't feel like a house anymore
because as soon as you look over in that
corner and you see your laptop staring
at you and you're like [ __ ] or maybe a
lot of people don't think this way
uh but i know for me i would see that
laptop and i'd be chilling on my couch
and i feel guilty that i'm not working
because i love i love
what i do right so for me
i have to like resist from working right
i have to tell myself wait i need family
time like if i didn't need to sleep
i would be like okay cool i had my
family feel cool i want to go back to
work like that's how i am and you're the
exact same way like if you didn't need
sleep or [ __ ] to eat or [ __ ] or
whatever you'd probably be working too
cause it's just we love what we do yeah
um
so having that in my home space was very
stressful and i didn't know how to
unplug because i'm like [ __ ] i feel like
a lazy [ __ ]
sitting on my couch when i'm like [ __ ] i
could be way more productive
and i'm like my shit's right there [ __ ]
i'm just gonna be productive and i
couldn't i couldn't
disconnect from it and i'm like [ __ ] i
need i need to separate these spaces
because this is not going to work for me
like my mental health was
was not good
um and i think that that's another thing
that people are feeling where it's like
your home is supposed to be your safe
haven but that's now where you're
getting reprimanded and now that's where
all these bad conversations are
happening or this is where a bad meeting
is happening or some [ __ ]
i don't know because catastrophe's
happening like it's it's the worst like
now that room has this like weird
heavy energy to it that i'm like nah bro
take it away i'll go back to the office
and i'll [ __ ] cuss every direction
that i'm going and [ __ ] i hate it
there but i'm so grateful when i can
leave that energy behind and be like
okay fine
out of sight out of mind baby i'm here
with you now like another conversation
that i hear i'm like man i don't know if
that's really good is um
people like hit me up that work like a
regular job right and they're like hey
you want to grab lunch uh this day or
i'm gonna go to uh my doctor's
appointment during this time and i'm
like wait don't you have work during
those hours he goes yeah i work from
home
and i'm like damn i don't know if that's
and that
that attitude is a good attitude to have
towards something that you're trying to
work hard at so you could be proud of
yourself at right like everyone that's
in a job they're trying to get promoted
right that's what i'm assuming people
want to do good at a job get promoted
get higher responsibilities higher pay
and advance but you're not going to
advance if you have a
like that kind of uh
attitude towards things and also on the
flip side
if uh i like in my company if i found
found out that someone was applying and
had that attitude i'd for sure like oh
no like you have a very me me
type of uh how do i bend like all my
responsibilities around what i want and
you don't have that team mindset you
have a more of an eye mindset you know
so like i don't even think that's
conducive because now not only do you
have to be your own worker you have to
be your own manager and that's a lot of
stress too yeah i mean assuming it came
from that place but it could also come
from a place of like yo i'm a really
efficient worker and i already got it
all done maybe it's not a
yeah you know and that's also like that
that's also like a
so there is a there's a good advice like
that that's different you know like oh i
get all my work done before 11. oh i see
you cool but then the i get is more of
like my boss doesn't even know what the
[ __ ] i'm doing i can squeeze out two
hours and it won't even make a
difference
i get it you know what i mean yeah i
mean there's definitely perks to working
from home for sure i see it especially
like i'm grateful i get to work from
home sometimes when i have you know and
i have to watch taika because i'm like
[ __ ] man what a blessing so it has it's
it's pros and it's cons but to answer
that question specifically
um you know when you work from home and
getting that fatigue for me what helps
and
it helps you too because we always talk
about this is just going out for a walk
around the block
going out for a walk around the block
leaving like physically getting yourself
out of that room
for a little bit kind of decompressing
getting some sun on your skin
um if you can probably get like a good
little sweat sesh on like a quick little
workout maybe even take a shower
um
those little those little things for me
help a lot for me it's uh schedules and
then discipline to stick to the schedule
so i'm also a realist
so i'm like like let's say he was like a
buddy of mine right and he and like
let's see work together i mean how many
hours do you need to sleep a day where
you don't feel tired
and he goes uh nine
cool then it's on you to make sure you
get nine hours of sleep so if you need
to be in like let's say i'll just make
the math easy if we need to be in
by nine
you should probably
be asleep by 11 so that you have 11 to
eight and then you have an hour to get
ready
and even wind down at probably 10
so set that schedule
okay cool
but after four hours i get tired or
whatever cool then no coffee in the
morning have your coffee right when
you're about to get tired or do you have
enough time to split your hour lunch
into a 30-minute eat 30-minute nap and
then just have a set schedule and stick
to it like no matter what and because
ultimately if your goal is i want to be
optimized and i want to maximize my
performance so i can keep advancing in
life but i don't want to let my biology
hold me back then i would say structure
your life so that it maximizes your
biology but now it's up to your own
discipline to stick to it so that you
can advance forward that's way better
advice than the tips i just gave that
that's what i would well because that's
what i noticed for myself yeah yeah
you're a big scheduler yeah cause i'm
like
it's um
if you already aren't that disciplined
it's very hard for you to do things that
you're not normally doing yeah right so
to me i'm like let's lower the barrier
of entry because we want to be
successful right success builds success
so how can we get you successful in a
small way
so the first small way is let's just get
you enough sleep every night yeah
because that already makes you a
different being a different creature
right like imagine like a hungry tiger
versus a full tiger full tiger might see
a gazelle walk by and go
hungry tiger is like
this is the same creature
right so like let's get you in the mode
where you're firing and your engines are
on let's do that first we're that way
you're already prone to being productive
and successful and then eventually like
turn those notches more and more and
more that's how i see that's why
schedules to me are so
um are so dope and so critical because
literally
the schedule like you know like in any
of those special operations assessments
like rangers raiders navy seals all they
really do
is change the schedule
and then your world turns into hell
you know all they're really doing is
um you're gonna sleep at 2 a.m and then
wake up at 4am
and then literally just by changing the
schedule your [ __ ] brain is [ __ ]
like [ __ ] two hours of sleep at night
what the [ __ ]
and then like and then also
let's make you tired
so we'll work out a little bit more and
we'll make you hungry right so tired
hungry lack of sleep the toughest of men
crumble
and we'll hold that for two weeks and
we'll see who lasts that's all they're
really doing
so that's why that's why the schedule is
so important it can literally transform
someone that's such a [ __ ]
dope explanation
really you son of a [ __ ] picture
smart really yeah
yeah schedules will literally optimize
you turn you into the hungry tiger or to
the full tiger that's not gonna do [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] what i said listen to bart
yeah that's why schedules to me um
are so so important if you learn how to
optimize and you recognize what you need
and you optimize it to that way
you will be surprised at your own
performance damn i'm so happy you're
doing a [ __ ] mentorship really i'm
like i seriously sometimes when we do
this goddamn podcast i'm just like
okay yeah and then what else would this
be
all right
wait what what do they what do i should
i do oh yeah okay i'll write it down
seriously
times 100 man don't sleep on it
uh your class is closed now but you are
gonna take uh about a month
to just kind of like uh dissect how this
first one went see what you can do
better but you can maximize um what you
need to keep throughout and then the
next one might be in like august
september yeah six so sign if you want
to sign up it's times-100.com
uh go there right now and then you'll
get all the updates on when the next
enrollment is i didn't mean to plug it
like i i didn't mean to do a shameless
plug even though i'm gonna plug all of
our own [ __ ] but um it just it just felt
like i
i literally like you [ __ ] melted my
brain by simplifying it so much right
like we've heard that saying like uh
complexity is the enemy of execution
right so like if something seems so
[ __ ] complicated you're like frozen
you're like i don't even know how to
move but you simplified it so much that
i'm like
wow
it really literally just is that and if
i have access to you in that way
and i know that now other people have
access to you i'm gonna put it out there
because holy [ __ ] you have some really
great gems you know and then like for me
to selfishly hold that you have this
mentorship program and not put it out
there for other people to sign up when
i'm seeing the benefits just personally
i'm like why would i be selfish like
that so what is it again uh
times-100.com i'm such a good wife you
better be massaging yourself
i'll massage it between your legs oh no
no no no you're you're always missing
the spots no no no i plugged you you
missed you missed the [ __ ] knots dude
not plugged and they're right in front
of your face there's only one knot i was
playing one knot and you always just
[ __ ] go around it and i'm like
i was blessed like this i bless it like
this look look
well if if if bart ever teaches a course
on sex don't sign up for that one okay
sex dash 100.com
oh my god okay on that note thank you
guys so much for submitting these
questions these are always so rad
because it makes us go into different
corners of our brain so that we can
properly answer and like it just it
triggers so many cool memories and like
discussions and i absolutely love them
so we will for sure continue to do these
thank you so much for following us and
thank you so much for listening um to
this whole thing we're hoping we're
hoping you're having a great day a great
week a great month and if it's not don't
worry about it you can turn it around
you have the power to do so um but until
next time see you next week goodbye